what's the product of 33 and 21 pause
the video and try to solve it the
traditional way is to write 21 under 33
then 3 times 1 is 3 3 times 1 is 3 again
write a zero here 3 times 2 is 6 and 3
times 2 is 6 3 9 6 33 times 21 is 693
but this took a lot of time want to see
a better way okay here goes
3 times 2 is 0 6 3 times 1 is 0 3 and we
add this product with this one 6 plus 3
is 0 9 693 took us less than 5 seconds
don't worry by the end of this video you
will be very comfortable multiplying
two-digit numbers first digits of both
then second digits of both and then the
Umbrella approach product of these two
plus the product of these two with the
same approach what will be 43 times 17
pause and try 4 times 1 is 0 4 3 times 7
is 21 3 times 1 plus 4 times 7 is 31 1 2
plus 1 is 3 & 4 plus 3 is 7 731 is the
answer easy wasn't it but wait where
exactly do we write these numbers the
unit's digit of these numbers should be
under the second digit from the right of
the number on top hence we wrote the 9
under the 0 and the 1 under the 2 if you
forget which products to add just think
of an umbrella or a mushroom product of
these 2 plus the product of these
now take a slightly tougher 176 times 97
give it a try it's easy just that the
numbers are bigger this time 7 times 9
is 63 and 6 times 7 is 42 9 times 6 plus
7 times 7 is 54 plus 49 which is 103 we
wrote the three under the second digit
from right of the number on top to four
plus three is seven three six plus one
is seven seven thousand 372 is our
answer
63 is the product of the first digits of
each number 42 is the product of the
second digits of each number and 103 is
the sum of the product of these two and
the product of these two numbers
here are three examples for you which
you should be able to solve it 30
seconds flat
15 seconds idly but I'm giving you 30
assuming it's your first time 31 times
24 62 times 27 38 times 90 2 your time
startsnow
let's solve this quickly 3 times 2 is 0
6 1 times 4 is 0 4 + 2 + 12 is 14 744 is
the correct answer
okay next 6 times 2 is 12 2 times 7 is
14
and 4 plus 42 is 46 1674 is the answer
the last one 3 times 9 is 27 8 times 2
is 16 + 72 + 6 is 78 6 1 plus 8 is 9 7
plus 7 is 14 we write a 4 and carry the
1 over 1 + 2 is 3 38 times 92 is 3000
496